why'd you want to sit down and talk
today
oh gosh there's so many um
stories you know and i want to explain
what happened
i'm not racist neither is pierce racist
walk us through what happened
on wednesday wednesday i arrived at the
studio
late one of our showrunners was going up
the stairs
she said do you want to um clear up the
piers thing again i said
hey if you want me to i will then
at 8 minutes to 11
our showrunner says how do you feel
about maybe one of them doesn't agree
with you
and i said well that's all right too
okay thanks
sharon said what unfolded on air felt
like a betrayal from her co-host
after a pack they made in february there
was a situation in february
carrie anne was given a question to ask
elaine and carrie anne didn't want to
ask it but it came from the producers to
ask elaine and it was if
black people can use the n-word why
can't
white people use the n-word i would love
to hear what you have
which is a very naive question to ask
we all know why so elaine got very upset
with her response carrie anne started to
cry
so we agreed we would never be
surprise each other with questions if we
thought the other one hadn't been
prepped
and we said we will never put ourselves
in this situation again
where we set each other up so we all
agreed as women
got you back i finished saying what i'm
saying and then cheryl asked me these
questions
which i didn't know and they were
written questions and then
elaine's reading her questions stand up
for
anti-racism and i'm like
i've been set up don't try and cry
because if anyone should be
crying it should be me and
i went like how dare
you all do this to me i'm your
sacrificial lamb
so in the break i'm like talk to me
cheryl talk to me
what is going on she wouldn't i lost it
even further
sharon did take to twitter the next day
and apologize saying quote
to anyone of color that i offended or
let down i am truly sorry
i panicked but she did not publicly
apologize to cheryl
i want you to hear from me do you regret
how things spun out of control with
cheryl
regret oh my god cheryl's my friend
of nearly 11 years what do you want to
say to cheryl
i love cheryl i love shaw i've
apologized to cheryl she's not gotten
back
and i i can understand cheryl needs her
time do you understand how
people could look at and say you telling
her not to cry
could look like you are attacking cheryl
oh i was having i was having a go at my
friend
i got too personal with cheryl i should
never have said about her tears
i should never have dismissed her
feelings
on national tv ever but i
said it i have to own it and i was so
angry i cannot begin to tell you not
with cheryl
not with elaine not with anybody but a
company that i've worked at for 11 years
what was the goal do you think what was
the goal because i think that cbs was so
horrified with peers for the things he
was saying because remember
harry and megan it's a cbs interview
i had sided with peers so
it's the cancel culture isn't it throw
her under the bus
and our two show runners were crying and
then they said
that we were told to ask these questions
from the executives
the executives who they wouldn't give me
names
i've seen you handle some very hot and
hard topics
why did this throw you because i just
felt
this is the biggest setup ever and i'm
falling into it and i'm going deeper
down this hole a spokesperson for cbs
tells et
they are quote very mindful of the
important concerns expressed and
discussions taking place regarding
events on the talk
the show will extend its production
hiatus until next tuesday
as we continue to review these issues
i'm sorry i don't believe a word she
says meghan markle
for someone with that large of a
megaphone that was
unbelievable yeah i never agreed with
it i agree with his freedom of speech
he's a provocateur
i kept saying show me where he's been
racist
show me show me show me i don't know
tell me
educate me let me read it right and but
in many ways that was
your job to know his background
because he's your friend he's my friend
and for the times that i have worked
with him
i have never ever been a party to
anything
in his company what has ever been racist
ever have you talked to pierce since
this yeah sure he checks in on me every
day he feels really bad
because me standing up for his right of
speech
has got me where i am today
today leah remini became the second
former co-host of sharon's to accuse her
of using racist language at the talk
the season one co-host told journalist
yashir ali sharon would refer to julie
chen
who's chinese-american as quote wonton
and slanty eyes
this days after holly robinson pete said
sharon had her
fired for being quote to ghetto sharon
denies both claims
people who are let go along the way
get pissed off i'm the big girl with the
big mouth so
they fire it at me but i'm not a fool
don't accuse me of something
that's a lie what do you think they're
going to come back with out of this
investigation
all i said was hey i want an
investigation i want to know
who was the executive that said to ask
me these questions
and i want to know why i was left out to
dry
on national tv what do you want to
happen with the show
um i wish that we could go on
and have a adult conversation
calmly and work it out but
i don't know whether we can i don't know
whether it's gone past that
but i don't know whether i even want to
go back
i don't know whether it's i don't know
whether i'm wanted there
you